what's going on there reject nation greg
and john here today we got ourselves the
official trailer or trailer two for
light year the movie about a movie
within a movie that's right we learned
this after we did our first trailer
reaction that this is a movie
basically when the creators first
developed buzz lightyear they imagined
that the toy of buzz lightyear was based
on some blockbuster film that is what
they have brought to life is that
blockbuster movie that exists within the
toy story universe and another thing we
got to clarify too i thought this
sarcasm was ridiculously clear in the
last trailer reaction especially because
we've reviewed toy story 4 also the fact
that we were stating really wrong facts
about what happened in the toy story
franchise we're very familiar with the
toys we've seen toy stories throughout
our lives i can't believe you haven't
seen toy story why are you even covering
this then if you haven't seen it even
clarified after the reaction that we've
seen it
[Music]
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you
this voice sounds like a mix of chris
evans
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
[Music]
but get everyone home good luck
captaining on you
roger that
[Music]
[Applause]
get like interstellar in 2001 vibes yeah
hello buzz williams your personal
companion robot we'd like to comment
we're being pursued by uh
just a massive robot
whoa
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
oh but they're gonna sell so many of you
was that zurich
it looks kind of like zerg yeah it's a
big arm cannon
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
oh yeah
well that looks delightful absolutely
and and action-packed yeah and thrilling
they really should clarify what
what this movie is because there's still
a lot of people who are very confused
about what this movie is that he's not
the toy and that this is not a fantasy
world this is an actual guy there's a
space range does the buzz light your
cartoon subtly not is that it's not
canada because i thought that's weird
there are people who are still like kind
of up in arms about the whole thing i i
think the relationship with tim allen is
fine people he's doing the santa claus
show for disney plus
this isn't some disney woke agenda
liberal
thingy yeah that everyone spews out yeah
let's replace that white guy with a
different white guy this looks
delightful though this looks pretty epic
and the reason why i think they have to
clarify it is because i think it can
raise some confusion for people because
not everyone's going to read articles
and i feel like a lot of people jump to
the first conclusion that we jump to
which is that okay so i guess in the toy
story world there's an astronaut who did
space travel so why why would toys come
in on life be as magical when we've
already done space travel
all sorts of stuff in robots
but uh in terms of what we're getting it
does feel like a lot of grand sci-fi
movies but you know with that pixar
wonder and atmosphere to it i do get
vibes of like both 2001 and interstellar
just based off of like the type of space
travel adventure that this is setting
out to be but it's got a lot of that
pixar humor involved chris evans voice
though that seems like it's it's a
combination of like the kind of voice
you'd imagine chris evans to do but does
have some shades of like tim allen as
well in there yeah he's got some of that
inflection some of that cadence and yeah
it's a nice combo because it doesn't
sound just like an impression but it
sounds appropriately close enough to be
the buzz that you know and love but that
you can also kind of lose yourself into
the new experiences of it seems like
they're going kind of hog wild in terms
of just how much sci-fi influence
they're pulling in here and that's
really fun to me because this does seem
as much as there are familiar images to
have its own kind of unique aura and it
does have this air of discovery and
voyage you just listed off like two star
trek shows right that's right man the
next generation of there's so much
enterprise to it i feel like they're
going to like a deep space nine level
yeah man
picard yeah i like that because that's
not what i would have expected from the
tone like the tone actually looks like
there will be some legitimately menacing
you know like alien and or cyborg action
as much as it also looks like you know a
fun adventure that the family could get
into i feel like this could get a little
bit intense and i like when movies aimed
at the family are willing to kind of do
that was that zerg that was it was
emperor i'm pretty sure that was
everything everything about its design
would lend itself to think that it was
zerk which i hope they actually do kind
of make him a bit scary because remember
in toy story 2 and his first and you
finally see him because zurich has been
t since the first toy story movie and
then you see him uh in the beginning of
toy story 2 when you're in like kind of
like the movie realm fantasy of it all
you know when he comes out as it's just
a toy he is like really funny and stuff
but it would be neat if they like
because they see he's like kind of this
massive interpretation it's kind of like
when they did shredder and live action
tmnt movie that's kind of the vibe i got
with how they're bringing zerg to life
here and i think it would be cool if
they did make zurich a little bit more
on the scary side here because like what
you're talking about with it's the level
of peril that this is actually bringing
in the trailer itself i would love that
and of course this socks character i'm a
cat lover got four of them so i love
cats and that socks cat is going to sell
like a moat
that is just design it's literally a toy
in the indus
it's a toy in the movie
yeah
the least they're trying to mask this
it's just like you're gonna love it
you're gonna get one that's gonna give
you white noise they'll fall asleep i
wonder if the starman song will be the
theme song to it it's the only song
they'll play will be like shipping off
to boston and the departed they'll just
play it every five minutes the second
buzz does something cool well i'm also
thinking about star commander as well
star command will lead itself to have a
much bigger ensemble of characters and
right now the trailers have been mainly
light buzz lightyear focused i'm curious
that they will be able to make an
ensemble stand out a lot more granted
like the main takeaway you gotta have is
the buzz lightyear solo adventure
there's other characters in there
no
bureaucracy buzz
so we gotta make sure everything's by
the book
that's true
i'm sure he'll have some foils there but
this looks really fun uh it doesn't feel
like toy story and i like that and it
feels this does feel like the
blockbuster that would inspire toys this
is because it's kind of on on a metal
level yeah and then it feels very
exciting and i'm glad that it feels
exciting yeah like it's been a minute
since i've seen that first trailer and
this one gave me that same shot of like
oh wow this looks like it's gonna be
pretty dang engaging all right guys what
you think of the light your trailer
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
we'll catch you guys soon